Musik Sagt Bescheid, wenn wir laufen, dann fange ich an, lustig zu sein. Hol schon mal Luft. Und vorher, vorher definitiv nein, vorher gebe ich mir keine Mühe. Ich muss noch eine Facebook-Nachricht schreiben tatsächlich. Wenn wir schon laufen, dann würde ich kurz unsere Hörer in den Arm nehmen schon mal. Ja.
Kann ich schon? Florentin? Kann ich schon? Ich würde ja sonst einfach anfangen schon mal. Florian. Bernd. Wie oft bin ich dann durch den schönen Wald gelaufen und habe gesagt, Ich habe mir gedacht, Asse de he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da he, da wird eine sehr musikalische Folge, glaube ich, denn wir haben einen musikalischen Gast namens Cajon, El Cajon. Auch hier mal wieder die Frage, was macht es mit einer Sprache, wenn es Cajon heisst, aber Cajones sind ja die Eier, die man in der Hose hat, wenn man, sagen wir mal, einen sehr nach vorne hin getriebenen Mann. Das ist immer so ein Glücksspiel. In den ersten fünf Minuten zeichnet sich schon ab, wie die Folge wird und er ist schon wieder in dem Koronis-Modus, in diesem Kichernden Hihi. Er hat sich auch, wir waren gerade bei Lidl, und er hat sich auch gekauft zwei Eier, diese Auslöffel-Eier und hat jetzt schon den ganzen Weg zurück Wortspiele gemacht mit Ich habe ja heute meine Eier dabei und so diese ganzen Gangs. Habe ich nicht und der Beweis dafür ist, ich habe mir auch einen isotonischen Drink gekauft. Ja, aber kein Mensch weiss, was ist isotonischer. Das heißt, es wird eine ganz isotonische Folge. Ja, aber was heißt das denn? Du konntest mir heute nicht mal erklären, wie Magnete funktionieren, du Kasper. Du bist von vorne bis hinten gelogen und erstunken. Deine ganze Persönlichkeit beruht nur auf ausgeschnittenem Pappkarton, der sofort in sich zusammenfällt, wenn es mal nur kurz anfängt zu regnen. Eine Maske, ich bin eine grosse Maske, aber eine Maske mit isotonischem Sportdrink. Und ich verbinde, also lass uns mal so eine Assoziationskette durchspielen, weil ich finde, was verbindest du mit isotonisch? Ich verbinde Sport damit. Isotope. Isotope, okay. Also Chemie und Sport. Irgendwas dazwischen ist es offensichtlich.
Sport, Sporty. Aber es ist schon gesund, oder? Also ich meine, manche Biere sind auch isotonisch. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was es heißt. Ich habe mir ein Überraschungsei gekauft. Das ist ein bisschen einfacher zu verstehen, tatsächlich. Nein, aber man nimmt es ja auch sowieso nicht ab. Wir sind heute mal wieder im gleichen Raum wie in der letzten Folge. Wir haben ein Fenster zu unserer Rechten und die Sonne scheint uns ins Gesicht. Zu meiner Rechten. Und die Sonne scheint uns ins Gesicht, wir haben frische Luft, kommt von draussen herein. Wir sind beide so eine ganz entspannte, isotonische Folge, soll ich Sie nennen. Es erinnert mich ein bisschen an die Schulzeit tatsächlich, weil wir haben auch ein bisschen früher Feierabend heute gemacht. Das heisst, man hat so ein bisschen schlechtes Gewissen, aber es ist gutes Wetter. Das ist so ein bisschen wie schulfrei, so ein bisschen, man schwänzt Latein. Genau, man schwänzt letztens zwei Stunden Sport irgendwie, wo man den Sportbeutel aber am Anfang eh schon nicht mitgenommen hat, weil man genau wusste, man hat keine Lust mehr die letzten beiden Stunden auf Sport. Und es ist eh wieder nur Gymnastikball dran und wo man am Ende eh eine Eins bekommt, wo man als Junge ein bisschen disabled ist. Und ja, wir haben von vornherein auch gesagt, wir nehmen heute mal auf, relativ früh und ja, jetzt sind wir hier, sozusagen schwänzen noch ein bisschen, unsere Kollegen schuften noch, der Schweiss ist ins Gesicht geschnitten quasi und wir beiden nehmen jetzt hier unsere Folgen auf. Lass dich einfach mal reden, ich lass dich einfach mal reden. Mach mal, wir gucken, wo es hinführt. Und je länger du redest, glaube ich, desto eher redest du dich in Verlegenheit. Mach mal. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube mittlerweile in Folge 53, in der wir jetzt sind, keine Ahnung, bin ich mittlerweile schon so weit, dass ich einfach auch eine Stunde lang alleine reden könnte. Wollen wir mal eine Folge machen, in der nur du sprichst, in der nur ich spreche und gucken nach, welche besser ankamen. Nee, gucken, welche besser ankamen. Ich glaube, ich würde mich darauf sehr lange vorbereiten, intensiv vorbereiten. Glaubst du, einer von uns ist beliebter als der andere? Ja. Ich glaube nämlich nicht. Ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen so ein Chemiespiel. Es ist so wie Asterix und Obelix. Ich habe ein besseres Gefühl, wie öfter du Chemie und China und so sagst, glaube ich, dass die Sympathien eher auf meine Seite rücken. Ich glaube, es ist so, man denkt immer, man würde einen lieber mögen, merkt aber, dass wenn man nur den hat, dann fehlt was. Fehlt der andere, ja. Ist das auch privat so, dass wenn ich lange fehle, dass du, nee, überhaupt nicht. Na gut. Cajon ist halt, glaube ich, irgendwann entstanden und seitdem haben alle Bands nur noch Unplug gespielt. Ist ja auch so das Mandudiao, ne, die kennt man ja, eine relativ erfolgreiche schwedische Band.
Eine Cajon-Band.
Die haben ja wirklich auch Rockmusik gemacht und haben die halt ein MTV unplugged direkt als erstes Album oder so rausgebracht und haben dann Dance with Somebody irgendwie veranplugged und seitdem waren die dazu verdammt, nur noch unplugged zu spielen.
Ich glaube, das Geheimnis des Cajons ist, dass es nicht aussieht wie ein Instrument, weil wir haben ja schon oft übergeredet das Problem, du bist musikalisch und du willst irgendwie eine Frau rumkriegen, aber du willst es jetzt nicht so offensichtlich machen, so ich habe heute mein Fagott dabei, ha ha, komisch, zufällig auf der Hausparty, ich habe mein Fagott dabei, na dann spiele ich jetzt auch mal was, sondern du kannst einfach so tun, oh, du sitzt auf einem Schemel einfach hinten und irgendwie dann singt vielleicht mal jemand irgendwie das halbe Gummibärchenlied, weil Luke Mockridge kurz vorbeikommt und du klopfst so auf dem Ding rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und plötzlich auf dem Stuhl rum und dann so, ach nee, Quatsch und dann, ach ja, guck, mach du mal mehr. Und dann holt er noch den Schellenkranz raus und das Tampouri und dann ist das Tampouri und dann, wie geht das los. Genau, genau, genau, die Maracas, die Maracas, die haben alles bescheuerte Namen, oder? Kucarachas. Und was sind dann Maras. Und was sind dann Maracas? Maracas sind Spinnen dann, ne?
Maracas sind Kakerlaken.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe ja deswegen auch immer so ein Tambourin dabei.
Weil alle denken, ist es ein lustiger Hut, ist es eine Bauchtasche oder so.
Aber du musst immer ganz vorsichtig gehen, damit es nicht klimpert, damit du dich nicht verrät.
Deswegen schleiche ich immer so. Deswegen habe ich mein Hoverboard eigentlich auch gekauft, damit man es nicht hört. Aber ich glaube, ein Hoverboard ist ganz schlecht, weil du hast ja keine Federung und jede Erschütterung im Boden übersetzt dich direkt auf deiner Caron. Doch. Das Weirdeste an dem Ding ist, dass die Reifen, da ist keine Luft drin. Sondern? Es ist nur Gummi einfach, das ist ein ganz, ganz seltsamer Stoff. Aber kannst du dich nicht mit deinem Cajon aufs Hoverboard setzen, mit der Tambourine
in der Einhand, wo der Marakas in der anderen Hand einfach als musizierender Blitz einfach durch die Innenstadt schiesst? Da würde ich dich gerne sehen. Da würde ich viel Geld dafür bezahlen, dass ich das mal sehen kann. Im Gegensatz zu dem todtraurigen, schlecht frisierten, halb mit Senf eingeschmierten Stefan, der jeden Morgen aus dem Regen zur Firma gefahren kommt und sagt,
oh man, mir ist wieder nichts eingefallen, ich bin wieder, oh weiss ich nicht, lass mich doch mal vor die Kamera. Ich glaube, wenn diese Figur, die du immer aus mir machst, wenn die wirklich existieren würde, wäre sie extrem traurig, also eine ganz, ganz kümmerliche Figur, die du gerade aus mir machst. Welche Szene aus deinem Alltag hast du mir heute noch mal beschrieben? Du bist gestern Abend, weil dir so langweilig war, achtmal zum Kühlschrank gegangen und warst dann so frustriert, dass nichts drin war, dass du dir nur vom Kiosk nebenan Ben & Jerry's Eis gekauft hast. Ben & Jerry's Half-Baked Eis gekauft hast. Aber was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Half-Baked und Cookie Dough? Half-Baked ist halt mit Schokolade noch. Ach so, aber ich finde Cookie Dough tatsächlich besser. Half-Baked hat auch so halbgebackene Brownies da drin, die halt noch so ein bisschen roh sind. Ich glaube, es ist massiv ungesund. Cookie Dough ist ja hingegen sehr gesund. Du hast letztens behauptet, Ben-Jerrys-Eis hätte 230 Kalorien pro 100 Liter. Ich habe einfach abgelesen. Ich habe nicht mehr mein Gedächtnis benutzt. Ich habe nicht mehr mein Gedächtnis benutzt, ich habe einfach nur abgelesen. Ja, aber es ist schlicht nicht unmöglich. Widersprichst du gerade einer Packungsanzeige oder was? Nein, aber hast du dich einfach vielleicht verlesen. Da hast du statt Portionsgrösser gelesen, statt 100 Gramm oder sowas. Kann sein, dass ich fett gemeint habe, aber es ist einfach 200 Gramm pures Fett da drin. Pro 100 Gramm, ja. Ja. Tatsächlich. Nee, aber hast du diese Petition mitbekommen, Vanilleeis zu verbieten? Nee. Weil Vanilleeis so langweilig ist? Ehrlich? Ja, anscheinend irgendwie, weil man sagt ja auch Vanilla als irgendwas in seinem Grundzustand. Also das erste WoW, World of Warcraft, das noch keinen Untertitel hat, ist WoW Vanilla. Einfach weil es so normal schlicht langweilig ist. So. Da fällt mir was zu ein, und zwar habe ich mir bei Lieferheld neulich mal, um den Mindestbestellwert zu erreichen, noch ein Eis dazugekauft und Ben & Jerry'sEis auch, das zieht sich ein bisschen durch mein Leben und das hat sieben Euro gekostet tatsächlich und dadurch habe ich dann den Mindestbestellwert erreicht und hat das Restaurant mich daraufhin angerufen und hat gesagt, wir haben kein Bellingerries-Eis mehr und da habe ich gesagt, dann können Sie es bitte einfach streichen, dann werde ich es einfach nicht gerne und dann hat er gesagt, nee, aber Sie haben mir das Geld ja schon überwiesen per PayPal und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, aber Sie haben Sie haben das Eis nicht. Also ich habe etwas bezahlt, was gar nicht existiert. Und dann musste ich mir ein anderes Eis. Und zwar hatten die dann nur noch eine Eissorte, nur Vanille. Dann habe ich sieben Euro bezahlt. Dann hätte ich einfach gar kein Eis gerne. Und dann meinte er, schenken Sie uns dann sieben Euro oder was. Und dann habe ich gesagt, nein, natürlich nicht. Aber die überweisen das auch nicht zurück. Dann habe ich mich bei Lieferhalt beschwert und dann habe ich jetzt einen 5-Euro-Rutschein bekommen.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich letztens ein KFC-Menü bestellt und hätte es, weil ich es missverstanden habe, weil KFC sehr schwierig ist zu bestellen, hätte ich aus Versehen...
Weil die alle Spanisch reden oder was ist der Grund?
Ja, tatsächlich, weil die so viel Fett in den Ohren haben, die verstehen dich nicht.
Deswegen das Problem ist, ich hätte fast ein Menü bestellt, hätte aber gesagt ohne Pommes und ohne Getränk und hätte dann einfach viel zu viel gezahlt, weil ich nicht verstanden habe, dass in dem Menü Pommes und Getränk dazugehört. Mach du noch mal, du bist der Musiker unter uns. Ich höre jetzt mal einen geilen Beat raus, warte. Okay. W? Okay. Warte, ich stell mal Mikro auf dem Boden. Okay. Aber du hast alles zugestellt, du hast ja die Snare. Nee. Okay, welchen Beat mal? All the singing ladies, all the singing ladies, all the singing ladies, all the, nope. Das ist auch immer ein langes Mal geworden. Stefan, kannst du bitte aufhören, wir spielen hier Rummikum, nehmen wir an Enderparty. Bitte, ich hab den Gang, du hast nicht, wenn der Gang hinten raus so leise wird, dass er einfach, man weist schon, okay, es war nur Crap. Ich würde es gerne nochmal hören. Kannst du den Gang nochmal bitte dezidiert darstellen? Stefan, bitte sei leise, wir versuchen hier Rummikum zu spielen. Das ist das einzige Partygame eingefallen, ist mir eingefallen. Das ist ein gutes Spiel. Ich habe neulich bei Toys R Us das Spiel, habe ich Chewie Louie gesehen, also Looping Louie nur mit Millennium Falcon und Chewie. Also eigentlich so die beiden besten Universen zusammen gemorpht in ein geiles Spiel. Ich würde dir echt gerne mal so einen Peilsender oben hängen, einfach so wenn du es nicht merkst, einen Peilsender in deine senfverschmierten Haare stecken und dann einfach zu gucken, wo du dich so rumtreibst. So ganz abstrakte Formen in ganz Köln und immer so gucken, wo ist er gerade, weil sich zuhause, nein, aufzoomen, nein, aufzoomen, nein, aufzoomen, was in der Hüpfburg Sonderverkauf, was macht er denn da? Im Smallland, warum, was wäre er da? Im Smallland unter vier Lagen Bälle ist er begraben, was macht er denn da tatsächlich? Was macht er da, oh mein Gott! Hältst du was dagegen, wenn man dich die ganze Zeit orten würde und sowas? Wäre das ein Problem für dich? Nee. Nee, eigentlich nicht. Wir haben gerade noch eine Pause rausgeschnitten, du hast zehn Minuten lang nachgedacht jetzt, aber wie bist du zu dem Ergebnis gekommen?
Nee, eigentlich habe ich nichts zu verbergen tatsächlich, es ist immer so ein bisschen, ja, ich bin halt zu Hause, das ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig überraschend, aber so gehe ich einkaufen, ich mache nicht viel, tatsächlich, aber ja, wie ihr dabei seid bei unserem Unterhaltungs... Wir beide sind ja im Moment so ein House of Cards Fieber, oder?
Ja.
Wir lieben die Serie, die neue Staffel ist erschienen.
Und du hast mir gesagt, dass die Länderspracheneinstellungen bei Amazon Prime einfach massiv scheisse sind. Kommt ein Knaller-Thema, ja. Ja, pass auf, wir sind doch beide der Meinung. Und dann habe ich mich neulich verkauft. Ich habe nämlich die deutsche Staffel gekauft, obwohl die noch gar nicht erschienen ist, und habe dann Amazon geschrieben, Entschuldigung, ich habe einen Fehler gemacht. und dann haben die gesagt, alles klar, dann habe ich den Preis wiederbekommen, habe die englische gekauft und dann haben sie mir gefragt, ob ich noch Verbesserungsvorstelle hätte und dann habe ich einfach aus unserem Gespräch vom Vortag einfach reingeschrieben, dass wir mit den Länderspracheneinstellungen unzufrieden sind und dann hat sie gesagt, wow, Herr Thies, das ist eine sehr, sehr gute Idee, reiche ich sofort weiter und habe geschrieben, das wäre bei Netflix auch besser und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, ich nutze selber nur Netflix und es ist echt viel besser. Oh mein Gott, so hat sie so eine Goldader getroffen, irgendwie so, hier hat es die große Geschäftsidee gewittert und jetzt bin ich anscheinend so ein riesen Gesprächsthema da in Amazon Prime. Du bist der neue Head of PR auf den Gängen. Ich bin auswendig, wurde ich jetzt eingestellt als der neue, der Chef, Head of Technik Department und ja, also wenn du Fragen hast und Verbesserungsverschläge, könnt ihr es einfach an mich richten. Ich tatsächlich bin ein großer Fan von Feedback-Sachen, ich benutze das immer bei solchen Seiten, ich werde dann aber auch relativ schnell sehr direkt und sehr unhöflich, sonst immer so, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, vielen Dank, ich habe grosse Interesse an Ihrer Portage. Früher war ich auch so, ja. Aber ich sch ich schreibe dann so, Leute, bitte macht doch die Scheissuntertitel, dass man sie ausstellen kann, ihr Kackdeppen. Habt ihr eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden? Warum sollte man das denn nicht wollen, dass man es nicht ausstellen kann? So, weil das einfach auch keinen Sinn ergibt, warum man es nicht machen kann. Warum die einfach davon ausgehen, dass es niemanden gibt, der im Film... Hat sich ausgestellt, es war ein Stummenfilm und die Untertitel waren gewollt. Ja, aber ich will das auch manchmal nicht sehen. Ja, aber ich finde das ganz grossartig. Stell dir mal vor, es gäbe statt nur mit Untertiteln die ganze Filme nur mit so einem Gebärdensprachetypen die ganze Zeit unten drin. Ja, nö, das kann man nicht aussteilen, einfach die ganze Zeit. Du schaust ab jeden Film nur mit diesem Gebärdensprachentypen. Oder nur mit Audiokommentar des Regisseurs. Ja, was dir auch geil findet. Warum gibt es keine DVDs mit AudiKommentar eines Fans zum Beispiel? Gibt es sowas? Es gibt tatsächlich eine der besten DVD-Boxen überhaupt, der Matrix-Complet-Box, wo alle drei Filme und alle Kurzfilme, alle Animatrix und eine grosse Doku und so. Und da gibt es auch tatsächlich drei Kritiker, die sich alle Filme anschauen und tatsächlich bei dem zweiten und dritten Film sehr, sehr negativ auch werden und den Film mehr oder weniger zerreissen einfach. In der offiziellen Blu-ray-Box. In der offiziellen DVD-Box, aber das ist supergeil. Und das ist genau die Art, wie ich mir wünsche, dass Leute mit ihren Filmen umgehen und nicht wie motherfucking George Lucas, der rumschnippelt und an die alten Filme nicht mehr mehr zugänglich macht, sondern auch sagt, okay, es gibt einfach eine Fankultur, es gibt eine Popkultur da draußen und zwei und drei finden halt nicht alle geil. also warum das auch diesen Element des Kultes um diesen Film, um diesen Kosmos herum nicht auch implementieren, weil es ist ein Teil von Matrix, das einfach Teil zwei und drei scheisse ist, genauso wie es ein Teil von Star Wars ist, das Teil eins bis drei scheisse ist. Das macht es an sich popkulturell ja nicht schlechter. Ja, es macht es zum Kultfaktor noch mehr. Das erhebt es auf so einen Thron, dass man auch, weil ganz ehrlich, die besten Filme kann man auch hart kritisieren, deswegen sind die besten Filme auch immer die, die am meisten parodiert wurden. Man sagt zum Beispiel auch die Star Wars Filme wurden wahnsinnig oft parodiert, natürlich weil die Schwachstellen haben, aber diese Schwachstellen machen es ja auch erst so ein bisschen zu diesem Kultfaktor, weil der perfekte, perfekte Film würde nicht parodiert werden können und es dementsprechend auch wahrscheinlich nicht... Das ist halt wie so ein Leben von so einem Promi, weißt du, du hast ja noch so einen Absturz irgendwie, Britney rasiert sich den Kopf und so, das ist halt dann die Phase, aber dann will man auch wieder wissen, okay, wie geht's weiter und so ist es bei einem Film auch so. Ich habe sehr oft mit Kundenzentren das halt gechattet und habe mich auch gefragt, ob es irgendwie ein Zeichen von Einsamkeit oder so ist, aber dann kam mein Essen nicht und dann habe ich gedacht, wie weit kann man gagmässig in so einem Chat gehen, ohne dass man verzweifelt wirkt und einsam.
Und dann hat er gesagt, gut, ihr Essen, ich habe eben im Restaurant angerufen, es kommt erst in einer halben Stunde. Und dann habe ich geschrieben, gut, ich mache mir dann schon mal einen Toast. Und dann zurückkam, ich dachte, oh Gott, dann wollte ich es wieder löschen, aber ging nicht, weil es schon abgeschickt wurde. Und dann hat er zurück einfach so einen Trauersmiley geschickt. Ich glaube, das ist die grösste Demütigung für den Essenslieferantenservice, dass der
Kunde sich zum Verzweifeln zum Toast greift. Das dachte ich auch. Das ist das Schlimmste. Da schreibe ich, ich mache mir dann einfach schon mal einen Toast und die stehen dann für Premium, Essen und Foodora. Also dann hat er mir zurück zum Trauersmiley geschickt. Aber ich war letztens auf der anderen Seite und zwar hat mich ein Tourist am Bahnhof angesprochen, der hatte Probleme mit dem Fahrkartenautomat und hat Englisch gesprochen und hat mich angesprochen und er hatte sich eine Fahrkarte gekauft und hat anscheinend die gleiche Fahrkarte zweimal gekauft und hat aber gesagt, er hat nur einmal bezahlt und hat doppelt bezahlt mit seiner Kreditkarte und dann auch zwei Receipts bekommen und hat einfach doppelt gezahlt. Und er ist zu mir hingegangen und hat gesagt, ja, doppelt gezahlt. Und ich wusste,, kann ich mir natürlich nicht helfen, was soll ich machen.
Die Deutsche Bahn AG steht für Rückfragen nichts und da ist einfach so ein AGB aufgelistet. Genau, wir nehmen uns dem Problem an und melden uns zeitnah. Und dann habe ich einfach versucht, die Situation in was Positives zu finden. Und dann habe ich gesagt, oh, that's a big mystery, that's mysterious, how could this happen, that's weird. so ein bisschen als, oh, das ist ja jetzt was total Verrücktes.
Genau, so Wonder Man, so ein sehr verwunderter Typ. Wie kann das denn? Also eine Szene gemacht, alles viel zu gross gespielt. Oh mein Gott, Leute zugeholt, von der anderen Strassenseite. Kommen Sie mal her, was er eben erlebt hat hier. Ich habe das Wort Mystery bestimmt achtmal benutzt. Er dachte wahrscheinlich, ich kann einfach nicht gut Deutsch und versuche einfach die drei Worte, die ich habe, zu benutzen. Oh, that's a very big mystery. Mystery. Yes, I know the word mystery. Yes, I lost a lot of money. Yeah, but that's crazy. Oh my God, it's weird. Weird, I said weird. Weird. Aber ich bin in letzter Zeit viel wieder mit dem Zug unterwegs tatsächlich und was sehr interessant ist, weil ich erlebe wieder wahnsinnig viel, ich glaube die ICE-Geschichten kommen zurück. Bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm,achigen Menschen, nach Deutschland zu kommen und dann kommen einfach überall Züge, wo Eis draufsteht. Eis. Hier ist die Geschichte auch schon vorbei. Ich gebe ab an. Ich gebe ab auf Loret. Sie hörten, die Zielgeschichten. Nee, du hast eine Geschichte erzählt, zu erzählen. Nee, ach, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so interessant ist. Nee, weil da saß ich dann zum Regionalexpress und dann hat so eine Frau mich gefragt, so ja, was ist denn der nächste Halter? Ich sage, keine Ahnung, aber da vorne ist so ein Display, auf dem der nächste Halt steht. Und dann hat sie in diese Richtung geguckt, konnte es aber anscheinend nicht lesen. 404 Error, wo liegt das denn? Und hat dann so ihren Oberkörper so nach vorne gebeugt, um es besser lesen zu können und stand dann wirklich einfach zwei Minuten lang, Kerzengerade ganz still da und ich glaube, sie war so genau an dem Punkt, wo sie dachte, ich glaube, ich kann es noch lesen, ich muss nicht einen Schritt nach vorne gehen.
Aber sie hat es nicht überschätzt und stand dann da und du kannst in der Hand nicht nach zwei Minuten dann, naja, okay, gut, ich gehe doch nach vorne und schaue nach. Ging nicht, ich glaube, sie hatte sich selber schon so weit verfangen in dem Moment, dass sie nicht weitergehen konnte, sie konnte sich nicht eingestehen und nach drei, vier Sekunden musste es durchziehen. Und dann dachte sie sich, hat wirklich Buchstabe für Buchstabe entschlüsselt und stand eine Weile.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass ja hinter mir, hinter meinem Sitz auch nochmal so ein Display gewesen wäre, genauso wie auf der ganz anderen Seite. Ja, Sie können auch hier einfach gucken. Hast du das gesagt? Ja, genau. Aber sie stand erst mal einfach. Zwei Stunden stand sie da, um dazu zu zerschlüsseln. Und starrt durch die gesamte Länge des Abteils einfach durch. War sehr interessant.
Ich bin auch beim Zug gefahren und ich habe mir, weil ich bin ja ein musikalischer Typ, ich habe mir ein Pocket-Synthesizer gekauft, so einen ganz kleinen, einfach so einen kleinen, da kannst du Beats mitmachen, hör auf um den Kopf zu schütteln, so vehement und irgendwie jetzt wieder die Champagnerflaschen aufzumachen, weil du toll... Fehlkauf. Ich freue mich auf den Fehlkauf. Und dann habe ich aber Musik gehört und ich habe noch nicht genau verstanden, das ist so ein ganz minimalistischer Synthesizer, da sind nur Batterien hinten, da sind gar keine Schale, das ist einfach nur so ein paar Knöpfe und kannst so Zeug mitmachen und kannst die Kopfhörer reinstecken. Mega cool eigentlich, mega klein auch. Und ich habe aber noch nicht genau verstanden, wie das funktioniert, habe den aber mitgenommen nach Köln und dann saß ich da, habe Musik gehört die ganze Zeit und irgendwann kam meine Station, da habe ich dann die Kopfhörer aufgemacht und merke, dass das Ding halt in meinem Rucksack die ganze Zeit irgendwie so ein Beat abfeuert. Und dann muss ich da gesessen haben, irgendwie zwei Stunden lang und neben dieser kleinen, diese scheisse Zündersatz hat die ganze Zeit so ein Beat abgefeuert. Und man kennt das ja manchmal... Wie cool ist das? Beatman! Ich bin da rumgelaufen und dann habe ich aber nicht gehört. Alle so wicken so mit um dich rum und denkst du, geil, was ist hier los? Es bildet sich so ein Kreis und so ein Freestyle-Battle bildet sich neben mir. Ein mega unangenehm, weil auch Leute sich neben mich gesetzt haben, wo ich meinen Rucksack wirklich weggenommen habe, wo dann der Beat drin war, halt. Wie unangenehm. Aber wie ergehst du denn dann? Hab ich die Kopfhörer ausgemacht, hörte, dass das Ding abgeht und dann, oh shit, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung. Können Sie bitte Ihren Beat ausmachen?
Ja doch.
Das ist einfach so ein monotoner Beat einfach die ganze Zeit, das ist schon ganz geil.
Ja, vor allem, ich weiss auch leider nicht, ob die ihn gewechselt haben, weil er hat manchmal, wenn man auf Play rückt, so ganz seltsame Beats, die so ganz furchtbar klingen, so industriell, so pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, das kann unfassbar hässlich sein auch, weil ich das noch nicht ganz verstanden habe. Und ich weiss rückblickend nicht, welcher Beat da gelaufen ist die ganze Zeit, zwei Stunden lang, aber unfassbar älteren Leute in dem Abteil, glaube ich. Das ist schon geil, weil so ein Beat mit so einer Aura mit sich rumzieht, einfach immer so, dass alle in der Nähe sofort anfangen zu tanzen. Ja, vor allem, wenn du Musik hörst, hast du ja automatisch ein anderes Mindset. Wenn ich jetzt Walk Like a Net Egyptian höre zum Beispiel und Leute durch die Strassen gehen sehe, muss ich immer ein bisschen grinsen, immer ein bisschen lustig, wie Leute laufen. Wenn ich irgendwie Kamina Burana höre und Leute durch die Strassen gehen sehe, immer ein anderes Gefühl habe von der Welt. Und glaube ich, wenn du die ganze Zeit so ein Beat mit dir rumschleppst, dann wirkst du auf Leute ganz anders, als wenn du einfach... Dann kannst du ein bisschen kontrollieren, wie Leute dich sehen, weil du die Perzeptionen steuern kannst und du kannst die ganze Zeit Kamina Burana... Du kannst dir selbst eine Filmmusik geben. Was für ein fucking epischer Typ und der Auftritt auch einfach direkt. Vielleicht hatte man einen Lehrer früher, der war noch sehr jung und der ist immer mit Kamina Burana in den Klassenraum gekommen, was einfach... Was? Ein echt cooler Move ist. Ist das in Ernst? Ich wollte das gerade vorschlagen als Gag, aber wie geil ist das denn? Er war ein wirklich cooler Typ und der, mit dem spielte er aber noch Quiz-Duell die ganze Zeit, er ist einfach ein cooler Typ so. Das sind die coolen Typen. Und der kommt wirklich, der kam immer mit Cabine Burana in den Klassenraum rein. Ba ba ba ba ba. Und dann ist er in den Klassenraum gekommen. Wie gut ist gut ist das? Das ist so eine gute Idee. Und direkt natürlich mega Autorität. Ja klar, natürlich. Vor allem, wenn er so einen riesigen Umhang anhat. So ein Chor, so ein Chor hinter ihm herkommt, der das singt. Ich habe letztens hier in der Tonkabine, wo wir gerade sitzen, habe ich Tonaufnahmen gemacht für unseren tollen Einspieler, den wir gedreht haben mit den Hörbüchern. Audio! Und dann habe ich in meinen Augen einen mega guten Gag gemacht, der aber komplett hängen geblieben ist, den nicht mal du gerafft hast, wo ich hier in der Tonkabine stand und du mit dem Realisator draußen standest und irgendwie hieß so, ja mach noch eine mal ein bisschen ernster.
Und dann habe ich Carmina Burana angemacht auf meinem Handy und habe den Text nochmal gesagt und hatte,
oder halt irgendwie so eine epische Musik, weil wir ja auch diese Playlist gerade haben mit der Filmmusik,
halt irgendwie so eine epische Musik im Hintergrund spielen lassen, und dann habe ich den Text nochmal genauso gesagt wie vorher und dann sowas, sowas in der Richtung und die hat es einfach bald, und ich so, nee, nochmal ein bisschen ernster, weil überhaupt nicht gerafft einfach, und ich dachte mir, scheiße, ey, der war nicht schlecht. Der war nicht schlecht, aber man hat es einfach nicht gehört, glaube ich auch. Weil ich den auch auf mein Handy direkt in der Hand habe, aber es ging blitzschnell irgendwie so, ja, mach nochmal eine ernste, okay, alles klar, und dann kam ich noch mal der ging das mit einem cooler Hintergrund. Mann, einmal ein bisschen fröhlicher, nochmal die gleiche Texte, nur mit fröhlicher Hintergrundmusik. Mann, aber das war auch so ein Moment, wo ich mir dachte, oh, tough crowd, man. Tough crowd, ja. Es ist auch blöd, wenn eine Fensterscheibe tatsächlich zwischen dir und dem Publikum ist. Hast du es oft schwerer, glaube ich. Ich glaube, Comedians aus Tonkabinen sind die unbeliebtesten Comedians. Oder so aus Fensterscheiben, so die am Fenster stehen und den unten vorbeilaufenden Leuten was zuschreien, glaube ich. Die sind auch unangenehm.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein Dimitri-Martin-Gag, der gesagt hat, dass Comedy-Veranstaltungen da am besten funktionieren, wo man beim Feuer am verlorendsten wäre.
Also man ist quasi am Strand, wäre furchtbar, einfach keine Crowd für eine Comedy, wohingegen in so einer Lagerhalle oder in engen Räumen, wo man einfach dem ausgeliefert ist, schon am besten. Hier ist es ein sehr guter Wettbewerb, der sich in der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der Zeit der ist richtig rum, alles gut. Jetzt muss er die Socke abziehen kurz. Sorry, Entschuldigung. Sinn und Vorwand. Aber du hast ein Mikro für, sagen wir mal, 500 Euro gekauft. Ja, 350 glaube ich. Okay, aber dann hast du einfach eine 2-Euro-Socke drüber gestülpt. Das war schon mal ein Gag, aber ich würde es dir mal ernst aufreuen. Ich hätte ursprünglich mal einen Popschutz, aber so einen großen Ring mit so einem Netz drin. Aber das war halt ein bisschen... Mach doch mal die Handbewegung für Netz. Für mich war es sehr lustig, gerade seht ihr nicht, aber er winkt einfach. Was ist denn so ein Netzm willst du Netz, weil ich gerade irgendwie bebildlichen, mir? Ich weiss ja wohl, was ein Netz ist. Ich habe ein bisschen das selber, das ist ein Popschutz. Ja, ja, ja, nee, aber halt ein Netz tatsächlich. Und es ist aber sehr unhandlich, das mitzunehmen. Deswegen habe ich mich irgendwann für die Socke entschieden, tatsächlich, wenn nichts, weil ich, man muss ein Mikrofon ja von zu Hause herbringen. Tatsächlich hatte ich ja erst das Mikrofon und lange keinen Popschutz und habe mir einen Popschutz versucht selber zu bauen und habe dann irgendwie so aus Pappe so einen Rahmen ausgeschnitten und da so eine Strumpfhose drübergezogen und so was das war, das war auch noch die alte Zeit, wo wir noch in der Garage gearbeitet haben. Kommt, weiter. Ich nehme noch einen Schluck aus meinem isotonischen Drink.
Merkt ihr vielleicht, wenn ihr euch gerade so ein bisschen vitaler fühlt, so ein bisschen aktiver, rausgehen wollt, joggen wollt, dann liegt es daran, dass wir isotonisch moderieren. Ja, komm, ich sehe es doch schon in den Augen, du willst doch, mein Gott, ja, du hast diese Woche ein neues Podcastprojekt mit den Changemen gestartet, komm. Er sitzt da wirklich wie so eine Katze, wo gerade ein Vogel vor der Fensterscheibe gelandet ist und sie so, was muss ich machen, um das jetzt machen zu können? Sag jetzt, du moderierst an. Hau rein. Serv, was hast du eigentlich die letzte Woche gemacht? Ich habe letzte Woche ein Podcast-Projekt
gestartet. Wirklich? Mit einem bekannten YouTuber. Echt? Mit Gronkh? Mit DeChangeman heisst er. DeChangeman heisst er. Der feine Mann. De, Vorname, Deet. Also die Abkürzung von De, De, Changeman, Wechselmann, weil er immer so ein sprunghafter Typ ist, mal gut drauf, mal nicht gut drauf, Changeman. Und immer Kleingeld dabei hat. Nee, deswegen nicht. Das ist Quatsch.
Und wir zusammen haben jetzt ein Podcast-Projekt gestartet.
Ich finde die Idee selber nicht gut, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Die Idee ist, wir hören jede Woche die gleiche, wir gucken uns jede Woche die gleiche Folge einer Serie, einer uns unbekannten Serie an.
Episode sechs oder acht der Staffel sechs oder acht der Serie Royal Pains. Und wir wissen nicht genau, worum es geht. Wir gucken uns jede Woche diese Folge an und machen dem danach einen Podcast auf, um über das Gesehene zu sprechen. Sehr geil. Wie viele Folgen habt ihr schon aufgenommen? Wir haben jetzt schon zwei Folgen veröffentlicht zumindest. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viele aufgenommen haben, ich habe irgendwann das Gefühl für Raum und Zeit verloren. Aber hört euch das nicht an. Und da entschieden dann lustige Gespräche und interessante Insider oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Nein, ich habe selber mal kurz reingehört und ich fand es relativ langweilig. Also ich muss sagen, mir gefällt, der Changeman gefällt mir nicht, ich gefällt mir selber nicht, ich sage sehr oft tatsächlich und so,
dann versteht man auch nicht genau, worum es in der Folge geht, weil wir das wahnsinnig unstrukturiert wiedergeben.
Man weiß nicht, was von uns ein Scherz ist, man weiß nicht genau, die Serie an sich ist auch nicht gut,
also man hat auch keinen Faktor, dass man dranbleiben will.
Und die Idee ist so ein bisschen einfach hängen geblieben in der, sagen wir mal, Brainstorming zu spät abgebrochen, würde ich sagen. Also, ein bisschen liberaler hätte man das Projekt schon gestalten können, so vom Konzept. Aber ja, müsst ihr euch nicht anhören eigentlich. Es ist nicht, ihr verpasst nichts. Also Podcast-Ufo ist schon ... Ja gut, aber ich meine, die Leute haben jetzt eine gewisse Toleranz, was Podcast-Qualität angeht, wenn sie sich diesen Podcast anhören. Deswegen nur mal zur Sicherheit, wie heisst das denn, wenn man jetzt wölte, sich das anzusetzen.
Last September in Andorra, das hängt nicht. Okay, schau mal. Last October in Andorra. Das ist, glaube ich, ein cooles Projekt, was man nochmal starten, was du vielleicht starten solltest. Ja? Soll ich mal was schauen?
Last Oktober in Andorra.
Auf Soundcloud zu hören, auf iTunes zu hören, zu hören, zu hören.
Habt ihr noch? Ja? Soll ich mal was schaffen? Last October in Andorra auf Soundcloud zu hören, auf iTunes zu hören, zu hören, zu hören, zu hören. Ähm, habt ihr eine Web-Prosse oder? Nein? Eine neu designte Web-Prosseite? Ich weiss nicht, ob ihr eine Web-Prosseite hat, keine Ahnung. Weiß nicht. Ja, cool, aber klingt auch gut, kann man mal ein bisschen am Laufen halten. Wollen wir denn eigentlich mal den Changeman einladen hier in dieses Projekt? Ja, du, können wir gerne machen, du hast ihn bis jetzt mal abgelehnt, weil er gesagt hat, dann haben wir einen Gast, der besser aussieht als ich, was natürlich Quatsch ist, weil niemand sieht besser aus als du, Stefan.
Findest du mich gut aussehen? Es schwankt tatsächlich. Manchmal gibt es so Bilder von dir, wo ich mir denke, ach Mann, ach ist er nicht, ach Mensch. Aber dann wieder, dann sehe ich dich, da ist immer so von der Seite,
ich sitze ja neben mir und dann sehe ich dich oft so von der Seite und so von der Seite hast du auch so, da kommt auch so diese Kinnpartie und diese Profile, wahnsinnig hässlich, auch weil ich so eine ausladende Nase habe, die geht so nach vorne, so spitz nach vorne, so eine angriffslustige Nase. Extrem lang, aber wenn man die von vorne ansieht, dann merkt man das ja nicht. Aber von der Seite ist das echt ein riesiges Problem.
Ja, ich finde dich nicht attraktiv, ich finde dich nicht schön. Also kein schöner Mensch, aber nett. Ah, das ist nett. Das ist mir auch wichtiger als Oberflächlichkeit. Wärst du lieber wahnsinnig gut aussehen oder wahnsinnig sympathisch? Lieber wahnsinnig gut aussehen, glaube ich. Wärst du lieber wahnsinnig dick oder wahnsinnig reich? Wahnsinnig reich. Sehr einfach. Ja, wir haben ja diese Woche auch WG-Casting gemacht, weil Jeff und ich sind auf der Suche nach WG-Mitbewohnern tatsächlich. In unserer Comedy-WG. In unserer Comedy-WG, wir brauchen noch ein bisschen ein paar Punchlines. Die Feetlines liegen schon auf dem Flur überall verteilt, aber es hat noch niemand die Zeit gefunden, die aufzuräumen. Und da haben wir ein Casting gemacht und da haben wir ganz viele Leute eingeladen. Und tatsächlich haben wir uns da ein paar ausgesucht anhand von Sympathie. Aber erstaunlicherweise setzt sich der Effekt ein, wenn man da mal ganz rational drüber nachdenkt, hat man am Ende auch einfach die ausgesucht, die am besten aussehen. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ob nicht einfach hinter allen Entscheidungen letztendlich nicht einfach doch immer Aussehen einfach mitspielt. Es ist ja für den Mitbewohner völlig egal, ob der gut aussieht oder nicht. Der muss ja nur sympathisch sein und irgendwie jetzt kein Arschloch oder sowas. Aber trotzdem am Ende sind es dann doch immer die Beste aussehen, obwohl es eigentlich in deiner Stellungssituation nicht... Du kannst den Leuten halt doch nur vor den Kopf gucken. Egal, was die in dem Moment sagen, niemand benimmt sich ja wie ein Arschloch beim WG-Casting. Die benennen sich ja alle nett, also kannst du eh niemanden beurteilen vom Charakter her in diesen 20 Minuten, wo man spricht. Irgendwie gab es mal so eine Studie, die meisten Chefärzte sind über 1,85 groß, also sind wahnsinnig groß. Damit sie auch grosse Patienten operieren können. Genau, damit sie auch oben drankommen und von oben auf die Schulter gucken können können. Wohingegen Urologen sind alle relativ klein. Die sind alle sehr klein, 80 Zentimeter im Schnitt. Aber erzähl nochmal bitte die Geschichte mit Master of Disaster Management, bitte. Ich kann leider nicht so viel aus meiner WG erzählen, glaube ich. Ich finde das eigentlich lustig. Ich finde das so gut. Ich muss doch noch mal drüber lachen. Das ist schon drei Wochen her. Wir haben das WG-Casting gemacht und dann kamen auch Leute und die haben dann immer die Frage, was macht ihr denn beruflich und so. Und da lernt man viele Leute von verschiedenen Berufszweigen kennen. Und einer hat Katastrophenmanagement oder so Katastropheningenieurswesen studiert. Master studiert. Und da hat er gesagt, ja, ich mache gerade meinen Bachelor,
aber man kann auch den Master studieren.
Und der Master, wenn man den besteht, dann kann man sich nennen
Master of Disaster Management.
Aber dann kann man auf seine Visitenkarte schreiben, Master of Disaster.
Ich finde das so lustig.
Verstehst du?
Master of Disaster Management.
Nee, das ist ja der Masterstudiengang.
Und dann bist du der Master of, also Master of Medicine oder Master of irgendwas anderes, Master of Arts oder Master of Mars oder Martial Arts und dann hast du halt Master of und der Studiengang heisst ja, nee, der Studiengang heisst ja Disaster Management, aber wenn du jetzt Master of Disaster Management wie Master of Disaster, verstehst du? Das ist die lustigste Geschichte ever. Master of Disaster Management, kannst du sein. Aber wenn du es zu Ende studiert hast, Master, ne? Den Master gemacht hast. Ja, ja. Of Disaster Management. Also wenn du den Studiengang Disaster Management bis zum Master studiert hast. Ja, dann kannst du dich so nennen. Ja, und wenn du The Universe Management studierst, dann kannst du natürlich ganz andere Sachen machen. Master of Disaster Universe kannst du dich dann nennen, nein. Nee, dann kannst du dich Master of Management nennen. Glaubst du, Miss Universe ist für eine Rasse, die nicht genau verstanden hat, wie grosses Universum überhaupt ist, ein relativ grosses gestochene Titel? Weil das einfach eine intergalaktische Arroganz ist, die sich die Menschheit, glaube ich, nicht leisten kann.
Voll.
Weil ich glaube, Aliens sehen mit relativ hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit besser aus als wir. Und dann haben wir ein richtiges Problem, glaube ich.
Ja, vor allem, wenn dann auch irgendwie Aliens mal kommen und mit der Regierung sprechen wollen. Also wir werden ja nicht zu Mr. President gehen, sondern zu Miss Universe offensichtlich. Ja, genau. Das stimmt eigentlich. Glaubst du, die werden auch so ausgebildet in intergalaktischen Angelegenheiten, dass sie dann auch so eingeweiht werden in UFO-Sichtungen und so? Okay, genau. Sie sind die schönste Frau des Planeten, aber wir müssen, weil das bürokratisch, haben wir noch ein paar Sachen auf sie, kommen auf sie zu. Wir haben einen kleinen Anstau auf Sie vor. Ja, genau. Wir haben immer zehn Punkte aufgeschrieben. Schauen Sie einfach mal drüber. Ganz kurz, also wenn Aliens kommen sollten, haben Sie dieses rote Telefon, wo Sie mit denen sprechen können. Wie Aliens? Naja, andere extraterrestrische Lebensformen. Aha. Und wenn Sie die kontaktieren sollten, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich. Ich will aber, dass Frieden herrscht. Ich bin Frieden sehr wichtig, weil alle Menschen sollen zusammen in Harmonie leben, auf der Erde und im ganzen Universum. Dankeschön, Frau Schmidt, aber Sie müssen trotzdem das rote Telefon dann nehmen und den Präsidenten anrufen, sofort. Aber ich möchte auch mich persönlich dafür einsetzen, dass nicht nur darüber geredet wird, dass alles besser geht, sondern dass auch was gemacht wird und ich kümmere mich ja auch um weisen Kinder zum Beispiel. Ja, aber sprechen Sie nicht mit den Aliens persönlich. Sprechen Sie nicht mit den Aliens persönlich. Ich kann auch Stepptanzen. Auf gar keinen Fall Stepptanzen. Das ist in zehn Dalaxien eine Beleidigung. Das mache ich schon, weil ich ein Kind bin und ich habe auch eine kleine Nummer vorbereitet. Und wenn die Musik ... Bitte rufen Sie sofort mit diesem roten Telefon den Präsidenten an. Der kann sich darum kümmern. Sie heissen nur Miss Universe, weil das der Titel ist für den Schönheitswettbewerb. Aber Sie haben nicht die Verfugnis, mit fremden Lebensformen zu telefonieren.
Okay, ich habe sowieso das Gefühl, dass mein Charakter am Ende dieses kleinen Hörspieleinlage verschwindet. Das habe ich auch, das Gefühl habe ich auch. Ich habe auch Gefühl, dass dieses Hörspiel sich dann... Kann ich ja sowieso nicht anrufen, wenn die Aliens kommen, weil die Folge endet ja in einer halben Stunde und das ist ja recht unwahrscheinlich, dass bis dahin noch eh ins Auftauchen.
Das war ein Hörspiel, das war ein Hörspiel, das war ein Hörspiel, das war ein Hörspiel! Mit Cajon. Unserem Praktikanten. Herzlich willkommen, schön, dass du da bist. Cajon Gutierrez, hallo. Hola. Hola, ticas eticas. Hola, hablo un poco de espanol. Un poco de so, eh, convieno, su cansan, de cos, de maruena. Naja, aber also ich bin Cajon, ich bin in Madrid geboren und ich habe wahnsinnig Lust, in diesem neuen Podcast-Projekt von euch mitzuarbeiten. Ich kann nur ein bisschen Deutsch sprechen, ich kann ein paar Wörter sagen, zum Beispiel Stefan Tietze ist ein guter, auch, das sage ich generell sehr gerne, weil es ein schöner Name ist. Es klingt sogar auf Spanisch toll.
Niedersprache klingt es toll. Deutsch selbst gefällt mir nicht so gut. Zu eurem Podcast ist zu sagen, dass mir auffällt, dass der Lockige von euch, Florentin, ja, der ist ein bisschen schwächer, er hängt ein bisschen hinterher. Aber man muss sagen, dass beide einen ausserordentlich guten Job für die Podcastszene Deutschlands machen. Ich selber habe das Gefühl, dass Spanien ein bisschen weiter ist, was Podcasts angeht. Wir haben diesen einen Torero-Podcast, wo wir uns die ganze Zeit eigentlich nur mit den Stieren unterhalten, vor den grossen Torero-Wettbewerben. Es kommt nicht wahnsinnig viel zurück, wir stellen sehr viele Fragen, aber der Stier antwortet meist nicht, weil naja, er ist halt ein Stier und die können auch nicht wirklich mit mir kommunizieren. Ich bin gespannt, wie sich die Podcast-Szene weiterentwickelt und so lange wäre ich gerne bei euch sozusagen ein Partikant. Danke, Caron. Vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Du kannst dich jetzt wieder an den Schaltpult setzen und schau einfach nur da, dass du Slack offen hast, ne? Hast du das eigentlich mitbekommen, dass ich die Bilder, wir haben ja Fotos von mir gemacht für diesen Trainer, dass sich die komplett eine falsche Person geschickt hat, acht Fotos von mir, zu einer Mitarbeiterin, mit der ich überhaupt gar keinen Kontakt habe, Nora, aber die andere Nora, Kontakt, das ist ja genau der Blick, den ich auch hatte.
Was, who, who the hell? Und dann habe ich ja acht Bilder von mir vor der weissen Wand gemacht und an sie geschickt. Und das Lustige ist, zu Hause habe ich nochmal dann an die richtige Person geschickt und dann habe ich alle acht Bilder ausgewählt und dann in diesen Chat gepostet und dann haben die so langsam nacheinander geladen. Und dann kam erst das erste Bild an, das zweite Bild, dann hat die Person, also der Cutter, der ist gerade geschnitten, angeschrieben, okay, cool, passt, passt, danke. Dann kam das dritte Foto, genau, das dritte Foto, und er so, ja, perfekt, da ist eins dabei, vierte Foto, und das ist alles schon auch gleich. Okay, passt, danke, und es ist echt nervig. Alter, komm schon, es wird immer streng. Ich bin vollidiot, da sind so immer wieder die Bilder neu hochladet. Ja, passt, danke, noch eins, perfekt, danke, und die Posen ändern sich auch immer und einer close und einer ganz weg. Du hast immer weniger an, auch, man weiß auch nicht warum. Okay, perfekt, also grossartig. Sehr, sehr lustige Situation. Bürogeschichten. Sie hörten Bürogeschichten, Bürogeflüster, Faxgeflüster. Ich habe neulich den Discovery Channel geguckt. Und die haben sich mehr gefeiert, weil es so eine neue Neuerung.
Und zwar gibt es ja immer diese, das ist ja schon länger so, dass man halt Haie und so von Aussterben bedrohte Tierarten markiert, mit so einem Peilsender, dass man immer weiss, wie die sich genau verhalten und wo die Populationen sind und so. Ich glaube, da hattest du sogar den besten Gag der Podcast-Ufo-Geschichte gemacht, mit dieser Schildkröte.
Und dann, wo wir gesagt haben, die ist gerade 15 Jahre alt, was macht die gerade so? Und dann hast du gesagt, die hört Avery Levine oder so. Oder nee, die Rechte. Wer hat die Rechte an dem Material, das die Schildkröte dreht, glaube ich. Also fast, falls sie irgendwie Nirvana hört oder so, haben wir dann gesagt. Ja, genau, genau. Ich glaube, das war immer noch der beste Podcast-Ufo-Gag aller Zeiten. Jetzt gucken wir mal, wie es weitergeht. Und dann sind die auf die Idee gekommen, es gibt ja jetzt auch Drohnen, dass man einen Peilsender hat und damit man die nicht nur die ganze Zeit orten kann, sondern die ganze Zeit filmen kann, so ein ganz gelbes, grelles U-Boot hinter den her schwimmen lässt, die ganze Zeit. Und dann haben die irgend so ein Hai, das ist halt so der Feldversuch, und jetzt hat irgend so ein Hai, schwimmt irgendwo draussen rum, und andauernd ist so ein ganz grelles U-Boot schwimmt fünf Meter hinter dem Hai die ganze Zeit. Es beschleunigt auch, es kann genauso schnell schwimmen wie der Hai, es ist einfach die ganze Zeit nervt es und ich frage mir auch so, wenn er zu seinen Haifreunden dann angeschwimmen kommt.
Hey, hey, Jerry, er ist schon wieder dabei.
Irgendwas ist anders an dir, ich kann es nicht genau benennen, aber irgendwie hast du dich verändert.
Er ist schon wieder da. Das U-Boot auch so bramiert, dass es Augenkontakt vermeidet. Ja, vor allem hätten die es nicht irgendwie in so einer Farbe machen können, die dem Hai nicht behindert beim Jagen. Es ist knallgelb einfach. Ganz schlechte Augen drauf gemacht und so ein Lächeln am Boden. Das ist kein Schein und es ist mega gelb. Es ist einfach die knalligste Farbe der Welt, damit die Forscher das wiederfinden, aber es behindert den Haie beim Jagen. Damit die Forscher ist 3000 Kilometer unter dem Wasser, als sie das Gelbe sehen. Und dann kommt der Hai an und spielt so ein jagen und dann... So eine gelbe Flosse, schaut sich auf. Und das dumme U-Boot, der dumme Bruder vom Hai, kommt dann wieder mit. So Seifenblasen, Blubberblasen, den rauskommen. Mega aufmerksam. Wie gut ist das denn einfach? Das war ja auch so lustig. Vor allem, ich war irgendwie der Einzige im Raum, also neben dem Fernseher. Bei der Regiebesprechung, ja. War ich so der, der gesagt hat, das ist vielleicht nicht so eine gute Idee. Ja. Weil das beeinflusst den Hai ja auch irgendwie. Er will jetzt auch bestimmt loswerden. Dann findet er an so Kreise zu dringen. Ja, das ist ganz awkward. Wir haben festgestellt, dass Haie die ganze Zeit im Kreis schwimmen, die ganze Zeit, und sie ständig umgucken, so paranoid so. Also ich glaube, ich weiss nicht, der Volk will jetzt. Aber dann immer so stürmt, ah, er ist schon wieder da. Sorry, du kannst ja bei mir übernachten heute. Ich dachte, als du Drohne gesagt hast, sie bauen so eine fliegende Drohne, die einem Vogel hinterher fliegt die ganze Zeit. Ja, das ist der nächste Schritt wahrscheinlich offensichtlich.
Da ist einfach immer zu langsamer, warte, warte, ich kann nicht so schnell, warte kurz, ja, okay.
Bei Rick and Morty, wo die den Planeten, neun Planeten suchen und dann ist einer halt viel zu klein, einer ist viel zu gross, keine Ahnung, und dann ist ein Planet, der ist schon ganz normal und dann geht die Sonne auf und es ist einfach nur so eine Sonne mit dem Gesicht drauf, die ganze Zeit nur schreit. Was einfach eine sehr gute Idee ist. Der Planet ist perfekt. Der Planet ist perfekt. Die Sonne geht auf, dann geht sie wieder unter. Ah, schon gut, das ist eine tolle Serie. Ohne Scheiss, warum hört ihr diese Folge gerade? Ihr könntet viel besseres angucken. Das freut mich ja wirklich. Ne, wir können ja mal sagen, was macht ihr? Schaut euch mal Ren & Stimpy an. Ich habe mir diese Woche die Komplettbox von Ren & Stimpy bestellt. Kenn ich nicht, kenn ich überhaupt nicht. Das ist die abgefachteste, abgefahrenste Serie, die es überhaupt gibt. Was ist denn das Florentin genau für eine Folge? Das ist mir, was schaut sich an, Ren & Stimpy kennen die meisten, kennen die 90s-Kid unter uns, die kennen 90s, so zwischen Sailor Moon und Heidi lief damals Ren and Stimpy. Mega gut. Erzähl doch nochmal mehr davon. Und schaut euch House of Cards an, schaut euch Utopia an, mega geile Serie aus England. Es gibt so viele geile Serien, die ihr anschauen könnt. Worum geht es in Utopia? Ja, um eine riesige Verschwörungstheorie und um Leute und Internet-Nerds, die das dann rausfinden und sich treffen und dann in Gefahr geraten vielleicht. Mega interessant, mega gut inszeniert, auch ziemlich gewalttätig, aber auch nicht. Vielleicht entsteht eine kleine Bindung mit Melanie, der Hauptperson, die sich vielleicht in Tom verliebt. Melanie, du kleiner Elefant, kannst fressen und bist überall bekannt. Kannst fressen? Ist das wirklich der Text? Äh, nee. Kannst fressen? Wow! Hey Melanie, er ist fressen. Fällt uns da nicht noch irgendwas anderes ein? Ja, kann leider leider nicht. Kannst du die Wahl bekannt? Kannst, was aber ist denn da eigentlich der Text? Kannst. Benjamin Döli, kannst du sprechen? Sprechen! Sprechen! Die einzige Fähigkeit, die hat! Kannst du sprechen, sprechen, sprechen, ja, ja, ja, ja. Komm, wir gehen mal ans Fenster. Wir gucken, ich wollte es einfach... Wir gucken mal, was es hier zu entdecken gibt. Ah, das ist geil, wir machen den Balkoncast. Oder den Balkast. Balkan. Glaubst du, Balkon kommt von Balkan? Wir gucken mal auf den Innenhof gerade. Tatsächlich ist es keine einzige Person da, die Sonne hat sich schon ein bisschen gegen Ende. Jetzt kommt allerdings da so ein Mann um die Ecke gerade, hat einen Hund an der Leine. Warum er denn eine Pistole in der Hand? Ne, das ist glaube ich noch ein Teil, ne, das ist jetzt eine Pistole.
Okay, vielleicht sollten wir vielleicht was finden, was zu machen.
Das Echen fällt.
Warte mal, da kommt jetzt noch ein zweiter. Ist das stehen geblieben gerade?
Jetzt hat er den Knarre auf ihn. Das muss man mal so souverän machen.
BABABABAB!
Oh, ich glaube, ich würde, müssen wir dann doch noch mal lieber reinkommen.
Machen wir mal kurz mal lieber zu.
Gut, verrückt, was hier alles geschieht. Naja, wir machen Unterhaltungsendungen, deswegen sollten wir vielleicht davon absehen. Naja, gut, Florentin, was ist sonst so bei deinem Leben, was geht sonst so vor? Lustige Dinge sind passiert. Ich habe, für mich war die Prank Week, ich habe ein paar Pranks im Büro gemacht.
Zum Beispiel hast du was gemacht so zum Beispiel?
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was du gemacht hast. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was du gemacht hast.
Erzähl doch mal, ja, genau.
Und da war so ein Installateur da.
Und du hast ihm ein Kick-Me-Schild aufgedrückt.
Nee, da war so ein Installateur da und der war glaube ich so zwei Stunden lang da, weil die Kaffeemaschine sehr schwer war.
Grosses. Sehr grosse.
Da musste die so reinrollen.
Ich nehmte einen Raum ein. Keiner weiss, wir trinken gar keinen Kaffee, keiner trinkt Kaffee bei uns, aber er war eine sehr grosse Kaffeemaschine.
Und ähm, dann bin ich oft an...
Danke an den Mann.
Komo, der Rade Steffen, der kann einfach jede Story noch einen Ticken geiler machen.
Er kriegt's immer wieder hin.
Ich wollte tatsächlich gucken, ob es einen Ausschlag hat, ob es einen Ausschlag auslöst am Interface.
Muss ich mal kurz. Nein, mein Gott, er war der Installateur eine Stunde lang da und dann bin ich in der Zeit irgendwie dreimal aufs Klo gegangen und habe jedes Mal einen anderen Song gepfiffen, so einen klassischen Ohrwurm-Song und ich wollte ihm jedes Mal einen anderen Ohrwurm geben und dann gucken, ob er beim nächsten Mal den Ohrwurm selber pfeift. Life in Plastic. Enough in Plastic. Enough in Plastic. You can brush my hair. And burn me everywhere. Everymation. Life is a creation. Ist das eine kreationistische Botschaft? Life is nuclear. Ich habe immer Nukleation. Dann bin ich okay. Mä-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A Also die ganze Zeit so rumhoppt am Strand, irgendwann steht er an der Tafel und erklärt dann irgendwie, wie man genau Kernfusion betreibt und sowas. Ich finde ihren Song ganz geil, eigentlich bis jetzt ganz ehrlich, es gibt nur diese eine Stelle da im dritten Refrain. Diese belehrende Stelle, wo sie plötzlich anfangen, Atome zu erklären. Und soweit ich mich erinnere, existiert das Wort Nukleation auch nicht wirklich. Also ich will jetzt nicht genau, in welche Richtung sie da hinwollen. Life is Nukleation. Wie oft ich schon in der Disco stand und gesungen habe, Life is nuclearation.
Die Musik geht aus und der Nuki! Oh!
Sorry, zwei Bier bitte.
Fährt auf seinem Segway davon.
Aber kannst du, wäre das mega geil!
Weil es halt konstant nur rudern und irgendwie alle möglichen.
Nee, auf der Stelle kannst du dich auch drehen.
Das heisst, und ich bin grösser als alle anderen.
Noch mehr.
Das heisst, du bist wie so ein Korkenzieher tatsächlich. Wir haben darüber gesprochen, über deinen Tanzstil tatsächlich. Weil ich habe dich noch nie tanzen sehen und ich würde dich ja nicht gerne tanzen sehen. Wir haben uns schon mal tanzen gesehen. Hä? Comedypreis. Da konnten wir ja gar nicht mehr unsere Glieder an uns lassen. Ja, stimmt. Da haben wir die Finger nicht voneinander lassen. Da haben wir die jetzt seit, wir haben rumzappeln da. Wir haben den Shaky Man gemacht, die Wave. Ich habe ein Video von dir, wie du auf dem Comedypreis tanzt, bemerkst, wie ich es filme, auf mich zuläufst, um meine Kamera in deine Obhut zu bringen. Ich kann mich daran erinnern, weil ich stockbesoffen war in dem Abend. Aber du bist ja eher so ein Fusstänzer, hast du gesagt. Ja, also mein Oberkörper muss man sich vorstellen, ist kerzengerade, ich verziehe auch keine Miene, die ganze Zeit so ein cooler Blick und dann … Die Füsse ausser Kontrolle. Voll nicht ausser Kontrolle. Ich habe keine Kontrolle über meine Füsse, wenn mein Song kommt, Single Ladies, dann rasten meine Füsse komplett aus und I can't handle it. Also einfach, es läuft dann so los und dann fragen mich oft auch Leute, ob ich das professionell mache. Wie schaust du, also mein grösstes Problem beim Tanzen ist das Gesicht. Das ist nicht nur dein grösstes Problem beim Tanzen. Achso, ich dachte jetzt, du gehst in die andere Richtung und sagst, das ist nicht das einzige Problem beim Tanzen. Achso, okay. Beides Gags, schön. Und deswegen stimmt die Chemie zwischen uns. He didn't say that. That didn't just happen. You wouldn't believe what happens at minute 52. Ü wirst nicht glauben, was bei Minuten 52 passiert. So die Jurassic Park-Geschichte, also man konnte, in Bernstein konnte man endlich, irgendwie hat man so ein Dino-Fossilien gefunden und so, man versucht das Blut daraus zu nehmen und so, man versucht dadurch die Vergangenheit zu rekapitulieren.
Und Bernstein heisst im Englischen Amber, Amber. Und ich habe geschrieben, weil man ja in die Vergangenheit guckte damit, Don't look back in Amber, war dann mein Gag herunter.
Don't look back in Amber. Und zwei Leute haben es mir gefallen. Erstens verstehe ich ihn nicht und zweitens hättest du doch viel leichter einen Remember-Gag machen können, oder nicht? Don't look back in Amber ist ein Song, ein sehr bekannter Song in der Popkultur. Echt? Don't look back in Anger. In Anger, ach so. Ja, das ist ja der Wortgag. Ja, ja, aber auch den kenne ich nicht. Ja, das ist das Problem. Warum hast du keinen Remender-Gag gemacht? Wenn ihr gerade in der U-Bahn saßt, sorry, sorry, dass ihr ausgerastet seid vor Lachen und Leute und Bekanntschaften gemacht habt. Falls ihr gerade den High irritiert habt, die mir gerade hinterher schwimmt mit eurem kleinen gelben Büro. Mit einer scheiß Drohne, dann sorry, sorry, dass ich gerade massiv zum Lachen gebracht habe. Bei Florentin ist es mir nicht gelungen. Aber dafür habe ich ja noch ein paar andere Gags heute. Apropos Amber. Aber du hättest mir auch ein Wake me up when September ends. Ja, aber das passt halt nicht nur auf einer Ebene, nur mit dem Amber-Wortspiel, aber nicht, dass sie dadurch in die Vergangenheit gucken wollen. Ja gut, Gag nach Hilfe, Zeitpunkt null, grüßt ihr später von mir. Bring dir deine Anaknote zu Ende. Ich würde echt mal gerne mit deinen Notizen jetzt improvisieren irgendwie. Ja, das können wir gerne machen. Quasi so Gag-Karaoke. Aber da ist das nicht so gut, weil dann gebe ich dir ein anderen. Gib mir mal ein anderes Gag-Dokument. Und gib mir auch du mal ein Gag-Dokument, dann machen wir jetzt mit verteilten Rollen. Das ist nicht schlecht.
Also, gibt es da eine Rubrik dafür? Okay. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, dinglelingleling, der das Podcast-Ufo, Dreh den Swap auf, Dreh Karaoke, äh, GagGaraoke, ja, alles klar, ciao.
Gagtausch, wo wir unsere Gagdokumente austauschen und versuchen mit den Notizen des jeweils anderen heisse Gags zu machen. Wohingegen, ich habe von Florentin jetzt ein richtiges Gagdokument bekommen, du hast von mir nur ein Dokument bekommen, wo du quasi, wo du schnipselt von meinen Gedanken siehst, die ich in meinem Podcast erzählen wollte.
Aber zunächst einmal, Papa, warum sieht dein Penis anders aus aus meiner? Ja, so kannst du dich einfach so Gags machen. Nur mein Sohn, zu allererst mal, dein Penis ist nicht irrigiert. Hui, nicht schlecht. Ja, die sind aber alle geklaut, glaube ich. Ich glaube, die sind gar nicht von mir. Okay, alles,. Der grosse Fun, der jetzt kommt in den nächsten halben Stunden, ist nicht von uns. Viel Spaß. Guckt einfach irgendwie ein Comedy-Special bei Netflix lieber. Aber wir könnten uns ja zum Beispiel jeweils Aufgaben geben, um die nächste Folge interessanter zu machen. Zum Beispiel? Zum Beispiel, dass wir eine Woche lang nichts essen. Comedy Gold. Damit wir einfach komplett geschwächt am Ende unserer Kräfte hier aufnehmen. Geil. Aber ich finde es immer geil, weil letztens Weihnachten ist das schon eine ganze Weile her, aber das Geile ist ja, dass wir wir hatten ja tatsächlich einen Weihnachtsbaum an Weihnachten. Ich weiß, was jetzt kommt. Und was ich da immer richtig geil finde, wenn du auf dem Amt bist, und dann gibt es ja immer diese lustigen Rüberschiebmaschinen, ne? Also diese Maschinen, wo man dem anderen dann immer so das Wechselgeld rübergibt und sowas. Und da dachte ich mir, wie geil wäre das denn, wenn du den Weihnachtsbaum, nee? Es Nee? Es waren zwei Geschichten, die eine habe ich mir mal erzählt. Das ist halt richtig eine Aufzeichnung, ist Heiligabend, Weihnachtsbaum. Mega Story. Auf dem Weg zu meiner Tante, wo wir Weihnachten gefeiert haben, lief so besinnliche Musik, läuft halt im Radio immer so ganz besinnliche Weihnachtsmusik und die Enkel kommen zusammen, die Kinder zusammen. Und dann wollten die halt um irgendwie, die wissen ja auch nicht genau, was sie an Weihnachten noch alles erzählen sollen. Und dann haben die angefangen, in den Forschern zu befragen, wie Bäume das eigentlich empfinden, Weihnachten. Und als Weihnachtsbaum stattzufinden im Wohnzimmer. Und die wollten wahrscheinlich einfach so ein behagliches Interview führen, aber der Forscher, der hat dann die ganze Zeit einfach nur Knallern, hat Wahrheiten rausgehauen und hat die ganze Zeit gesagt, nee, die finden das gar nicht schön. Auch der Geruch, das ist nicht irgendwie ein Enzym, was die aussondern, das ist einfach nur Angst, das ist sozusagen deren Todesschrei, weil die, das sind immer Schmerzen quasi, die aussondern. Man muss sich das vorstellen, das sind ein grosser Organismus, quasi viele Tannenbäume und die sterben einzeln und was man da kürzt, der Geruch ist ein Todesschrei und das Herz haus was rauskommt ist eine art blut kann man sich vorstellen die sind unfassbare qualen für den und hat sich ja was sind pflanzen die merken doch gar nicht doch das hat man mittlerweile festgestellt die merken das ist unfassbar schlimm was sie da machen schmerzhaft wir sind auch dagegen ja alles klar jetzt kommt erstmal last christmas von wem sprechen gleich weiter es war mega unangenehm und es ist so ganz seltsam abgedriftet.
Ja, aber was erwarten die denn auch, wenn sie Pflanzenforscher fragen, was mit der Pflanze passiert?
Ja.
Ey, weißt du, aber wenn du einen Brief an einen Astronauten schreiben müsstest, was würdest du da, was würdest du ihn fragen?
Wenn du eine Frage an den Astronauten stellen könntest, du schreibst einen Brief in Space?
Ich glaube, ich würde sowas fragen wie immer schön auf dem Boden bleiben. Das ist jetzt nicht wirklich eine Frage, aber du würdest erst mal Tipps geben. Tipp geben, bleib mal schön auf dem Boden, Astronaut, würde ich sagen. Ja, ihn auch nicht persönlich ansprechen, sondern nur Astronaut? Nee, und dann würde ich sagen sowas wie man hört keine Schrei im All. Auch so als Tipp, falls er schreit, dass er davon ausgeht, dass niemand kommen wird. Sowas.
Ich habe eine Frage an dich, was glaubst du macht so ein Oktopus den ganzen Tag? Also ich glaube, der verbringt sich sein ganzes Leben damit, sich die Arme hochzukrempeln,
oder?
Um endlich mal anzugreifen zu seinem Oktopusleben.
Hey, er hört da richtig was aus sich raus.
Oder?
Oder vor allem, was machen zwei Oktopusse, wenn sie sich begrüssen? Sehr awkward, wer gibt wem welche Hand, ne? Welche Hand und wie viele Hände und die sind der Begrüßungsfolger dabei wahrscheinlich sehr lange, würde ich meinen. Aber apropos Tiere, ich sag mal, es ist ein Skandal, der Berliner So ist in der Kritik, weil das Chameleon-Gehege ist seit sechs Jahren.
Leer. Die längstmögliche Pause zwischen Feedline und Punchline. Ja, den habe ich sogar rausgehauen. Ich glaube, den ging gar nicht so schlecht. Ja, ging ganz gut, ja. Die schlechteste Rubrik ever. Schlechter als Club Sandwich. Von den Machern von schlechten Rubriks wie Club Sandwich oder Topical Island. Wir sprechen von einem Heissluftballon in der Folge und haben aber das Mikro vergessen. Kommt jetzt zu Ihnen! Wow, wir haben nicht mal einen Rubriknamen!
Warum kann ich das nicht mehr drehen? Weil das ein Cajon ist, das ist ein Musikinstrument,
die kann man nicht drehen. Das ist ein grosses Problem, deswegen sind Orchester auch immer
in eine Richtung, gucken alle in eine Richtung. Oh Gott! Weil man die Instrumente nicht
Vielen Dank. Das ist das Problem. Deswegen sind Orchester auch immer in eine Richtung, gucken alle in eine Richtung. Oh Gott. Weil man die Instrumente nicht drehen kann. Aber es ist mir oft auch selber für mich ein Problem, dass meine Gag-Dokumente sehr kryptisch verfasst sind. Ich habe zum Beispiel geschrieben Telefon, ICE, Schrei und habe das seit Jahren in meinen Notizen gehabt und wusste nicht, was es ist, bis es mir irgendwann einfiel. Ich kenne die Story sogar auch, ich glaube, dir hast du schon mal erzählt. Ja, habe ich noch nicht im Podcast erzählt. Achso, dann hau raus. Also ich war im ICE und dann war eine Frau neben mir, die dann diese Durchsagen gemacht hat, dass man gleich, wann die nächsten Anschluss zugekommen und wo man gleich ist und so weiter, und hat den Telefon gehabt und hat dann halt ganz nett reingesprochen und gesagt, ja, herzlich willkommen in Heilbronn, ihre Anschlusszüge sind, sah dann aber schon auf dem anderen Gleis die Züge, dass sie schon viel zu früh da waren, hat dann das Mikrofon an seinen Körper gehalten und hat mich angebrüllt, was soll denn der Zug schon da, was macht denn da diese dumme Harschlöcher, der RE4 in Richtung Schwerin ist bereits am ... Was zum Tor, will macht er da? Oh mein Gott!
Aber sie hat keine Chance, dass sie ihn noch erwischen soll.
Er hat halt ganz eloquent gesprochen, aber hat zwischendurch einfach mehr die Attacken, Panik hat er bekommen.
Ich glaube, er hat geschrien, das ist grossartig. Ich glaube, die E-Mitarbeiter ist ein extrem stressiger Job, weil du bist ja immer bei den Stationen, es ist extrem stressig, Anschlusszug ist er schon da, wie sag ich es den Leuten, fuck, und dann hast du wieder 20 Minuten, wo du komplett gechillt bist, aber halt immer so einen, ah scheiße, wir haben jetzt schon eine Minute Verspätung, kriegt das noch hin, kriegt er noch die Kurve, kann er noch über den bunten Streifen am Boden fahren, damit er den Boost kriegt, kriegt er den Sprung hin und so, dass er die Zeit noch schafft, und dann bist du halt wieder, das wäre mega geil auf Autobahnen, so einen Booststreifen zu haben, diese Regenbogendinger. Oder halt so so Fragezeichenkästchen. Ich habe mal gedacht, wie cool wäre es denn, wenn Autobahnen, quasi wie auf Flughäfen, diese quasi Rolltreppen in der Ebene, also wenn das quasi so ganz grosse Laufbänder sind, dass man quasi meinetwegen 150 fährt, aber in Wahrheit 350 fährt, weil halt eine Laufbahn unter einem ist. Meine Antwort war, dass es wahrscheinlich einfach zu teuer wäre, das zu bauen. Alles da, das war der realistische Gag-Vernichter.
Wahrheit tötet Gag mit Stefan Tingo.
Recherche nimmt den Drive aus jedem Gag.
Diese Folge wurde ihnen gesponsert von isotonischen Drinks, Iso, Ihr isotonischer Drinks Nummer eins. Wir sind viel isotonischer als zum Beispiel Isomaniac oder Isobooster-Iso oder Isotope oder Isomatten. Nee, oder haltet sowas wie, ist so. Ist so. Ihr isotonischer Drink von Nestle. Nestle.
Nestle, sag mal, ja. Ja, aber jetzt, wir haben jetzt für die eine Folge, haben wir sie jetzt gesponsert, Herr Titzel, und jetzt gerade die eine Folge, die wir gesponsert haben, war sehr schlecht.
Äh, ja, ja, das ist ein, aber gut, wir haben ja Vertragsverhältlich schon eigentlich, was ja alles.
Ja, ja, finanziell ist das alles keine Sache, aber ich frage mich, warum die gerade so schlecht, ja, das kann man halt immer nicht, wir sind so wie so eine Sinuskurve, muss man sich das vorstellen, haben sich halt das immer leider, aber je öfter sie in uns investieren, desto grösst ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie eine gute Folge dabei haben. Aber warum haben sich denn gerade in dieser Folge die neue Rubrik Drehen Swap auf eingeführt, die ja. Ja gut, ich muss sagen, wir schwimmen halt so mit unseren Impulsen mit, das ist ein impulsiver Podcast. Ist ein isotonischer Podcast, hätten wir doch gesagt. Ja, ist ja jetzt unter uns so. Im Podcast würde ich natürlich isotonisch sagen, damit wir es ein paar mal öfter gesagt haben, damit es sich einbrennt in unsere leichtgesinnten, sehr leicht zu beeinflussenden Hörer. Ja, ist so, aber ... Ist so. Sehr gut, dankeschön. Kann ich vielleicht bei Ihnen anfangen? Womit? Sagen wir mal als Werbetexter oder sowas. Bei Ihnen jetzt bei ISO? Ja, wir haben jetzt diese neue Kampagne mit dem isotonischen Getränk mit Kirschgeschmack. Da bräuchten wir vielleicht noch einen guten Spruch. Ich hätte auch schon mal einen Lebenslauf eingereicht. Okay, dann schauen wir uns doch mal den Lebenslauf an. Hier steht 1996 Geburt. Was muss man sich darunter vorstellen? Ja, da bin ich geboren. Das ist passiert, wenn, haben Sie schon mal davon gehört? Grob, grob, ich habe jetzt die ganzen Fakten nicht immer da. Okay, wir sollten uns doch eher auf 2015 konzentrieren, wo ich den Grimme-Preis für die beste Frisur gewonnen habe. Ja. Haben Sie denn jetzt eine Idee für den kirche, isotonischen Getränk mit Kirschgeschmack? Ne. Wäre man noch einen mit Ananas? Ach ja, Ananas sehe ich mich eher. Fällt Ihnen da irgendein Spruch ein jetzt spontan? Spruch? Ne, Sie wollen sich als Bärbe-Texte bewerben. Ananas? Sie haben noch nie den Begriff Spruch gehört, oder was war jetzt das Problem an der... Ne, das Wort erkannt ist noch nicht. Ähm, Ananas. Krass, ist das ein Ananas? Ja gut, aber das ist auf Isotonisch nicht eingegangen. Ich fasse es nicht, ist die Ananas ein krasser Spass.
Basta.
Von Isso.
Wir brauchen noch 200 Zeichen mehr.
Ihr trinkt das Getränk, das euch
am Leben hält. Ihr müsst was trinken.
Und Wasser immer nur ist auch langweilig.
Isso, Isso
Drinks.
Von Leslie.
Gesponsert von Podcastsden uns vielen dank dankeschön
bäm mörderfolge geile danke mich bei dir Florentin gute Arbeit Stefan Stefan Stefan Stefan Geil. Wir sind's, eurer Florentin und wir freuen uns aufs Neue.
Nächste Woche gibt Gibt's welchen Gast? Vielleicht den... D... D... D... D... Oh... L... D... Donny... Oh... Tens... Boke... Bokeberg, genau.
Also, mach's gut. Wir sind dann raus. Abgehoben.
Ich glaube, wir werden jetzt noch ein bisschen, wir gehen jetzt noch nach Hause und setzen uns dann hin und machen den Browser auf, schauen wir auf einschlägige Webseiten oder auf Facebook, Twitter, vielleicht mal einen kleinen zotigen Clip. Und dann vielleicht auch mal lauter stellen.
Oder leiser.
Nach vorne skippen, nach hinten skippen. Die Helligkeit hoch machen.
Rauf, mit der Helligkeit, ne?
Rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf.
Und dann auf Play drücken.
Rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf. Immer in die Helligkeit.
Der Sonne näher. Immer einen Schritt näher der Sonne, tatsächlich.
Die Sonne ist untergegangen.
Fast.
Ein Jerkart.
Nein, ich sehe die Hände.
Das gibt diesen genialen Sketch von Conan O'Brien.
Vielen Dank. Fast. Ein Jerkart. Nein, ich sehe die Hände. Diesen genialen Sketch von Conan O'Brien, wo er sich als Soldat, da gibt es so ein Reenactment vom Bürgerkrieg und da hat er sich als Soldat verkleidet und dann trifft er so einen anderen verkleideten Soldaten am Feuer und dann will er so seinen Charakter üben, so ein bisschen so, kann ich mit dir meinen Charakter üben, dass wir einfach so ein bisschen unterhalten in Character und dann hat er halt so den mega überzummen den Charakter so, I don't know a lot about numbers and things and I can't read, I don't know much about dirt, I never heard of the sun. Das war nicht so lustig, dass sie das sagt. I never heard of the sun.
Die Aussage.
Aber du hast es gerade benutzt.
I never heard of the sun.
Um auszudrücken, dass man kein wahnsinnig kluger Mädchen ist. I never heard of the sun. Wollen wir jetzt nicht morgen eher mittagstreffen, dann ist ja Helde und so. Hä, wie meinst du? Well, I never heard of the sun. There's flaming ball in the sky.
Damn you, flaming ball. Damn you.
Sometimes you're there, then you're not. Calm down. What is it, you're playing with us. Calm down. Calm down and speak to us. I never heard of the sun. Es ist so gut, wie kann man das denn sagen, dass man noch nie von der Sonne gehört. Weisst ihr was, ich bin ein einfacher Mann. Ich kann mich nicht mit Zahlen aus, ich kenne nicht viel Geschichte, ich habe nur nie was, kein einziges Wort von der Sonne gehört. Das ist uncool auf Deutsch. Das ist grossartig. Auf Deutsch ist es nicht uncool. Aber wissen wir eigentlich, dass hier die Sonne nicht dreht und die Erde eigentlich still steht? Hm? Weil man den Himmel abgemessen hat. Die Sonne bewegt sich aber auch. Nein. Doch, klar. Um das Zentrum der Milchstrasse. Hä? Klar. Die Sonne bewegt sich auch, nur wesentlich langsamer als die Sonne. Ja, aber jetzt nicht so eher so lang. Merkbar, leger. Leger, so ein bisschen schlurfen. Ja, aber bewegt sich auch. Die Sonne schlurft. Und zwar sind wir, die Milchstrasse hat eine Spiralgalaxie und wir befinden uns ein bisschen in der perfekten Grösse im Abstand zu einem der Armen. Boring, this is boring, Stefan, the clearing things.
Also, gut, das war der erste Teil des Podcast-UFOs.
Kommen wir jetzt zum zweiten Teil der Sendung.
Der Doppelfolge, herzlich willkommen. Doppelfolge, Doppelfolge Podcast-UFO.
Stefan, wie würdest, wärst du lieber, wärst du lieber Herr über das Tierreich oder Herr über das die Pflanzenwelt?
Wärst du lieber Herr der Ringe oder Herr der Ketten?
Da du Ringe brauchst, um Ketten zu bauen, natürlich Herr der Ringe, weil ich dann mit dem Herr der Ketten einen sehr lukrativen Deal abschliessen kann, wo er seine Ringe für seine Ketten herbekommt.
Wärst du lieber Herr der Ringe oder Herr der Fliegen?
Oder Herr der Fliege. Ich war schon oft Herr der Fliege. Oder Herr Fliege. Ich war auch oft Herr der Lage. Der Herr der Lage, den mega ungute Film von Regisseur Stefan Dietze, der Herr der Lage, einfach ein Mann, der immer alles unter Kontrolle hat, einfach danach, nach zwei Minuten ist der Film vorbei. Leute, ich habe alles unter Kontrolle, alles gut, du machst das, du machst das. Der Herr der Lage, hä, findest du nicht so mega lustig? Geht so. Ich merke das, aber... Ich wollte noch Herr der Lauge draus machen, aber glaube ich hat es gar nicht gebraucht. Ui! Ja, mein Gott, ich weiß nicht. Aber welcher Herr wärst du denn gerne? Ringe. Ne, Früchte. Herr der Früchte. Glaubst du, in den Krieg, Früchte gegen Ringe, wer würde gewinnen? Früchte. Weil Früchte kannst du so sauer machen, dass sie die wegärzen zum Beispiel. Zitronen sind sehr sauer. Vielen Dank an den Fruchtexperten Stefan Früchchen, an dieser Stelle. Interessant, dass sie so heissen, tatsächlich. Ja, ich glaube auch oft, dass sich Familiennamen sind erst da und dann ist die Idee, was man machen will. Müller, okay, mache ich halt Müller auf und male Getreide zu Mehl. Oder Schmidt, okay, mache ich halt ein Late-Night-Show. Ist okay. Du bist aber heute on fire, ey. Meine Herren, nicht schlecht. Ich bin da drauf. Die Heizung, die Heizung. Wow, wollen wir ein Musical aufführen? Okay, die Heizung stellt sich zuerst vor. Wie so ein Andrew-Lloyd-Webber-Musical, wo sich erst die... Ich bin die Heizung. Ich mein, es wird warm um mein Herz. Ich wärme alle Menschen, doch mein Leben ist kein Scherz, denn eigentlich bin ich eiskalt.
Aber jetzt...
Ich bin der Mixer, ich mixe alle Früchte, und was in mich kommt, das mache ich klein und flüssig. ich bin das portemonnaie ich liege auf der Heizung, ich habe einen strangen amerikanischen Akzent, weil die amerikanischen Musicalsänger wesentlich billiger sind als die Deutschen und besser, auch besser sind. Wir sind auch besser, ganz ehrlich, sauer wie mein Freund, die Zitrone. Ich bin die Zitrone, wir sind seit zwölf Jahren zusammen. Ich brauche Sauerstoff, aber ich brauche auch die Sonne, ich hab noch nie von der Sonne gehört. Bamne, ja die Sonne, scheint mir auf den Bauch und macht mich glücklich. Ich bin ein Igel, ein Igel, ein kleiner, strachlicher Igel. Der Fallschrum in der Erde feststeckt. Ich habe Grossteile meiner Anatomie nicht verstanden, die auf den Brücken, aber was soll's, meine Fristbeine sind zu Grossteilen ausgestorben, deswegen, Igel! Igel, das geht an euch! Igel, Alter, Igel, oder Igel in Stuttgart, Igel, das geht an euch! Bin ich, bin ich eigentlich mit Stachelschweinen verwandt? Oder nicht? Oder nicht? Arme Luftballons können mir gar nichts! Ich hasse euch! Ich hasse Seifenblasen! Ich hasse euch so sehr! Seifenblasen hassen mich, aber viel mehr! Egel! Manchmal nennt man mich auch Egeil! Warum ist die Musik jetzt auch... Leute, Leute! Pornpornay, Heizung, wie kannst du... Ich bin ein Auto und ich merke mich, ich weiss nicht genau, über was ich gerade gefahren bin. Ich bin die Ampel rot! Halt, nein, ich will aber grün! Ich bin die Ampel gelb! Oh, ja, danach kommt grün!
Ich bin die Ampel blau! Nein, was zur Hö ich da in der Ferne? Die Liebe nimmt ein Geräusch wahr. Was genau passiert da eigentlich? Wir sind die Maulwürfe, wir werden diese Stadt einnehmen! Da kommen sie. In Scharen. Tausende über tausende Maulwürfer kriechen durch die Städte und die Gassen. Sie fressen alles auf. Wo wollen sie hin? Wir wissen es nicht. Erst die Kinder, dann die Ampeln, dann die Grossmütter, dann den Rest der Ampeln, die sie vorher nicht gesehen haben. Was genau war ihre? Wir wussten nicht genau, wie wir sie aufhalten könnten, doch dann haben wir entdeckt, dass sie nichts sehen und deshalb wahnsinnig gut hören können. Und da haben wir ihnen ein Schnippchen geschlagen. Beatman! Beatman! Rette uns! Du musst uns retten vor den Maulwürfen! Beatman! So rette uns! Du musst uns retten vor den Maulwürfen! Ich bin Beatman! So rette uns! Du musst uns retten vor den Maulwürfen! Ich bin Beatman! Ich rette euch! Oh Mann, Maulwürfe können gar nichts. Sie hören mich nicht, sie hören mich nicht kommen. Die Maulwürfe kommen uns zu fressen! Ich bin der Maulwurf, ich kenne kein Rhythmusgebühr! Aber ich weiss, wie mein Maulwürfzügel baut. das ist das einzige, was ich kann. Unsere Vorstellung von Architektur ist begrenzt, ist begrenzt. In der Tiefe, ich lebe im Dunkeln, denn niemand soll mich sehen, ich lebe im Schatten und kann nichts sehen. Doch die Fratze der Dunkelheit kann nur besiegt werden, wenn wir die Sonne zu uns holen. Und dann holen wir die Sonne. Aber es ist unmöglich, die Sonne zu der Erde zu holen. Wir müssen nach draußen, eine Invasion planen, damit die Leute uns die Sonne schenken. Die Sonne und die Erde sind seit jeher getrennt und voneinander durch unglaubliche Höhen getrennt. Aber dafür haben wir den Charakter der Liebe bereits früher etabliert im Musical. Die Liebe kann die Sonne und die Erde zusammenbringen. Und dann kam ihnen die Idee, zusammen mit der unmenschlichen Größe und dem Rhythmusgefühl von Beatman haben sie die Sonne auf die Erde gebracht, die Liebe hat ihnen geholfen.
Doch was ihr im Hintergrund hört, ist die Kernschmelze, weil einfach die Sonne hat die Erde zerstört, alle sind gestorben und...
Plutonium! Uran! Germanium! Germanium!
Ein Musical von Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze.
Ab morgen im Musical Dome.
Weiner Eickel. Herzlich verabschieden.
Und?
Hier kommen so ganz seltsame Geräusche, kommen wir gerade an in dem Raum.
Nicht erwähnen, das hat man gerade gehört.
Flüstern bringt halt nichts im Podcast.
Weil ich will direkt Mikro von meiner Nase ab.
Gut, wir hätten schon acht Mal abmoderieren müssen sollen,
deswegen sagen wir jetzt zum neunten Mal.
Ciao von mir, ciao, grüße an meine Eltern, bis bald.
Grüße an Stefan von mir und bis nächste Woche, haut rein und alles gut, ciao. Terima kasih.